bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation aux détenus corte vous de ce
discours d' emmanuel macron aux mureaux
c'était d'abord un discours qui était
très attendue depuis très longtemps en
l'occurrence ce discours sur la laïcité
qui intervient dans un moment qui est
très particulier où la france est
traversée par un certain nombre de
tensions communautaires le sujet
essentiel aujourd'hui pour emmanuel
macron s'était finalement l exercice
très compliqué parce qu'il fallait
afficher une ferme it et ne fermeté
réaffirmer les principes de la
république tout en évitant bien
évidemment de d'amalgamé l'ensemble de
la communauté musulmane de france qui
est la deuxième religion
faut-il le rappeler a disons des
courants qu'ils qualifient de
séparatiste d'ailleurs je ne suis pas
sûr que cette définition soit la plus
appropriée et des courants qui sont
clairement islamistes lille à nice
mettant d'une certaine façon une
revendication que politique
c'était un discours en tout cas qui
voulait à la fois s'attaquer à eux aux
formes les plus expressives de cet
islamisme tout en essayant de traiter à
ses yeux les causes sociales qui peuvent
être parfois le terreau propice au
développement de cette idéologie est ce
que vous avez été convaincu par ce
discours d' emmanuel macron il a évoqué
plusieurs grandes lignes de ce projet de
loi qui sera présenté le 9 décembre vous
avez été convaincus vous de votre côté
ces mesures annoncées par emmanuel
macron vont servir justement à lutter
contre ce séparatisme religieux dont on
craint beaucoup ici en france pour
certaines d'entre elles s'étaient des
mesures qui était réclamée par certains
nombre de spécialistes d'observateurs
d'acteurs qui ont se confronter à ce
sujet mais
la difficulté c'est aussi le timing de
cette intervention finalement on a
l'impression que il aura fallu trois ans
et demi à monsieur macron pour découvrir
cette réalité qui fracturent une partie
de la société française donc d'aucuns ne
manqueront pas de dire que ces mesures
dont certaines sont d'ailleurs de bon
sens en l'occurrence c'est à dire par
exemple étendre la neutralité de
l'espace public aux entreprises
délégataires de service public
surveillez les associations en tous cas
contrôler des associations si ce n'est
des contrôles est en tout cas faire en
sorte veut dire qu'elles signent une
charte de la laïcité c'est disons une
mesure qui va dans le bon sens c'est en
tout cas pour certains de ces mesures
c'étaient des mesures attendues mais
seront elles suffisantes
ça reste à démontrer pour l'instant
parce que d'abord un coup devez 100 pour
certaines d'entre elles un problème de
contrôle de légalité et voir de contrôle
de constitutionnalité
nous verrons ce que diront les juges à
la fois administratifs mais aussi
constitutionnel sur un certain nombre de
ces mesures
par ailleurs quand même il ne va pas
jusqu'au bout vraisemblablement de la
logique c'est à dire que on sent que son
discours est aussi sous tendu par une
culture
disons du regret ou de la mauvaise
conscience
le traitement social bien évidemment
d'un certain nombre de quartiers d'un
certain nombre de cités où prospèrent
les idéologies islamistes étaient
certainement une nécessité mais c'est
quand même oublier que la république
depuis un certain nombre d'années voire
de décennies a beaucoup investit aussi
dans ces quartiers donc être là là là le
traitement social est en soi
vraisemblablement insuffisant mais bon
le volet faut-il le reconnaître quand
même du discours d' emmanuel macron
c'était bien évidemment de répondre
politiquement à une menace politique
alors la france 1 est frappée par une
grave crise économique et sociale
provoquée notamment par la crise
au corona virus certains voient les
initiatives du président sur les scènes
d'intérieur et internationale et
maintenant cette présence en marge de la
loi sur les séparatismes comme des
manoeuvres de diversion qu'en pensez
vous arnaud benedetti pour ce qui
concerne à la fois la scène
internationale et le sujet dont nous
parlons aujourd'hui ce sont j'allais
dire qu'on roule à le premier sujet
disons une prérogative qui est une
prérogative régalienne du président de
la république qui consiste tout
simplement venir à être le land de la
politique internationale de la france
donc il est dans son rôle dans celui du
domaine réservé de la vème république
il va de soi que on sait très bien que
les usages de l'international pour un
chef de l'état c'est un moyen toujours
et notamment sur la vème république de
se représidentialiser lorsqu'on est en
difficulté sur la scène intérieure
ensuite le sujet le sujet du séparatisme
du séparatisme
il a mis ce qui l'a d'ailleurs désigné
tel quel dans son discours c'est une des
préoccupations qu' aujourd'hui lorsqu'on
interroge les françaises et les français
dans différentes études d'opinion
restent extrêmement forte
il n'en demeure pas moins que nous
sommes dans une situation en effet
sanitaire qui a des conséquences
économiques et sociales est extrêmement
importante pour la vie économique du
pays mais pour l'instant ils considèrent
que c'est vraisemblement à son coin
ministre et à ses ministres d'assurer
disons le service après vente du plan
d'eau du plan de relance
arnaud bennet été rapidement s'il vous
plaît vous dit
le timing de ce projet de loi est
curieux il arrive trois ans et demi
après l'élection des manuels macro
justement alors cette fois à la rive
fin d'année 2020 est ce que cette loi
sur les séparatismes emmanuel macron
n'est pas déjà en campagne pour la
présidentielle de 2000 22 avec pour
objectif de retrouver marine le pen au
second tour
l'affichage politique est une chose les
les enseignements que l'on peut tirer
aujourd'hui de cette déclaration ont
évidemment des applications électorale
on voit bien que pour emmanuel macron il
s'agit de 10 on réaffirme here le
discours sur les principes républicains
pour à la fois l'heure c'est un clin
d'oeil à l'électorat de droite
républicain qui considère qu'il s'agit
d'un sujet aujourd'hui prioritaire qu'il
faut traiter et éventuellement peut-être
aussi d'aller d'une certaine manière de
rationner sur une partie de l'électorat
du rassemblement national qui est
également extrêmement préoccupé par ce
sujet donc on ne peut pas totalement
exclure que aujourd'hui cette fois du
set loi contre le séparatisme islamistes
parce que c'est quand même cela le
principal objet de cette loi viennent
aussi d'une certaine manière nourrir une
stratégie électorale ce qui est en fin
de compte de bonne guerre à dix-huit
mois de la fin d'une échéance
présidentielle arnaud benedetti merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes rédacteur en chef
de la revue politique et parlementaire